when you're trying to make something
which is new and bold and dangerous you
risk going too far you know I was a row
rugby I was playing quite a high level I
can't stand watching watching Thrones
and knowing it's a stuntman that's doing
my bit so anytime you know I can I want
to do this time I've been in a fight the
night before I'd got in this fight with
this guy in McDonald's
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
gonna learn from one of the highest-paid
actors on TV Kit Harington and my take
on his top ten rules of success rule
number one is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best
I think unless we are pushing the
boundaries of what we are comfortable
viewing we're not making art we're not
mate and I think that's why game of
thrones' people have responded so so
much to Game of Thrones is that they
they're watching something which shocks
them which moves them which makes them
scared or angry I think the thing that
you risk is you can when you're trying
to make something which is new and bold
and dangerous you risk going too far
you're always going to take that risk in
Thrones I think we have gone too far at
times and in doctor faustus we
definitely did like it was it didn't
work in in some ways because it was too
much but I think unless you try you're
not pushing boundaries you're not making
art I had a few moments doing Game of
Thrones where you know you're very
intuitive and very kind of concentrate
on what you're doing and constantly
trying to improve it and and get it
better and better but every now and
again you have a moment and that a
couple work was just onset in this cloak
with this sword in this amazing castle
that they built and you just kind of go
this is really
this is just cool and this is what I
became an actor to do is to live this
kind of world it's every young actors
dream to play those parts where you're a
badass or fighter well is every kid's
dream yeah yeah I read the books and the
minute I got the part I went and went
and bought all of them and read them
mainly out of curiosity about what might
be happening also out of I felt I had a
source material there and whenever I've
got a source material I feel that for me
anyway I need to look at all information
I can gather about that fictional
character the first descript if you read
the first description of John it I think
I I think I for my audition I bought the
book read the first description of John
read a bit to get an idea of it and then
went in with that but it's it's already
in the book that he's quiet he's quite
sort of dour in a way he's he's he's
like the black sheep of the family
there was it within that first paragraph
about who he was and what is his sort of
essence was like gave me that first sort
of tap into how I should how I should do
that first audition and then that
template stays with you for six years of
who what character you've made that's
the way I if I have something like that
to go on the way I work is I'll look at
exactly what the writer or these writers
or the writer of the book thinks this
person is and try and tell that story
did you ever try your hand at football I
was always a rugby player when I was
young rugby yeah I was a scrum half
scrum after the little guy okay he's the
smallest guy and beating just yapping
scrappy yeah he's he's hard to catch and
he still takes the ball out of the scrum
off and he's a back and he and he gets
out to the bat mm-hmm but at the back
line you might say so did you realise
early on that perhaps acting was the
better way for you to go is that what
you're saying I remember the tackle that
did it yeah what was that I you know I
wish I was a rugby I was playing quite a
high level but there's something that
happens to young men when they go from
being like 16 17 years old to suddenly I
was playing at 18 years old and you know
when young men go from being young men
to men
mm-hmm and I remember that I got hit
with a tackle and I was in the drama
Society at the same time as being in the
rugby team and I kind of I thought I got
a I got to protect this you know the
moneymaker I've got I'm gonna protect
the moneymaker
one more hit like that to my face not
you know I can kiss acting goodbye how
physically demanding is your role on the
show and how has it different from other
roles you do your own stunts do you do
your own stunts yeah I do
have you ever gotten hurt have you good
yeah you get a knocks and bruises
nothing major I've no but you have to no
no no not the nose darling what's the
face I know I die it knocks and bruises
I've done far worse things myself in my
own time but science is I like doing I
can't stand watching watching Thrones
and knowing it's a stuntman that's doing
my bit so anytime you know I can I
wanted to do this dive free now and
again ask to be a stuntman but usually
it's me very easily it's me I imagine
he's kind of terrifying I imagine like
acting on stage in front of an audience
every single night it is but that's the
reason I think any actor gets into it or
any actor who starts in the stage
especially as you get into it for that
kind of thrill seeking reason in some
ways of the the adrenaline rush huh and
it's yeah I I love it and i forgot what
live performance was for a while and I'm
really enjoying it
this particularly this role in Pompeii
was hard right physically tough yeah I
mean when I got into it I sort of I I
looked at it and I was playing a
gladiator and I thought I better look
like a gladiator right so I said to the
director you know I would really like to
kind of Body Transformation thing for
this it's something that I've wanted to
do for a while like they trimmed fifty
day challenge or something like that
more of a gym thing yeah like I died I
wanted to you know if you do if you do
some research about gladiators they did
look like monsters huge right huge very
very cut very very chiseled how long did
you have to transform your body though I
had about five we lose one I put on ten
kilos
in five in four weeks and then I had in
another three weeks I had to while we
started filming the film I had to kind
of cut down those ten kilos against my
put on ten kilos and then lost 10 kilos
and then by that time you've keep all
the muscle but you just sort of carve
yourself I'd be a little bit like a
gladiator and when you're doing those
fight scenes which would be pretty
intense how long is the filming on those
long long long yeah hours and hours now
and and while you're not if you're not
doing the fights did filming them you're
in the in a room training for the next
one and and the director we had you know
the pool the director basically said you
know he would come in and we'd have
choreographed about ten fights you know
to show him and then he'd come in and
say no I don't like any and said that's
not that I don't like that when I don't
know that until you'd have to go and
relearn a whole but so by the end of it
you could pick up a fight pretty what do
you do you worry that you'll get
typecast with the game of front you know
meaning because it is I mean the cast is
so imprinted on everyone's imagination
that people think you are Jon Snow there
is that worry there is that idea will I
ever break away from this character but
I know when I wanted to get into acting
I wanted to just work I wanted to work
as an actor to do to act you know it's
just a is an honor in itself and this
enables me to do that and this may be a
defining role for me and you know but
it's it's gonna allow me to do lots of
other things and I don't worry about
that typecasting issue
I always think people other people worry
about it too much for me I'm like I
don't I don't see it as a problem the
first time Kate walked into the room I
remember thinking girl please let this
guy be good because I just had like an
image in my mind with mostly characters
I don't but with Jon Snow I had a image
in my mind of what he should not only
what he should look like but more what
he should kind of feel like a certain
brooding intensity and any kind of
haunted thing
do blue steel blue steel
Brewed steel so he came in and and any
nail it I mean he was just he was
incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
I've really admired his work and you
know I had seen him and his John snow
and I knew that this was a very
different part and he just came in where
we met at the reading and he just blew
me away
brings such you know a strong heart and
intelligent performance and yet very
sensitive it's nice when you when you
get to work with a friend and you know
and it and it actually works because the
other ways is not fun hardest scene I
had to play sorry one second I think
probably probably this there was the
scene okay sit
there was the scene with when Ygritte
dies it was so sad and it was it was we
had three weeks of night shoots so
everyone was very emotional anyway and
and the scene where I turn around and
she's there with the arrow and it was
this moment of like but it's funny so I
turn around and smiled because it was
did I didn't mean to I just did and then
they and then that seemed to work so we
kept it in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't talk okay
[Music]
look about that
[Music]
you
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because I've been on my
team asked me to eivin does most of the
research behind all of these videos so
had to do in my solid and make this
video if there's someone you'd like to
vote on for the next top 10 check out
the link in the description and go and
have your say finally I want to give a
quick shredded to best you Pro thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and taking that amazing
picture of you on the beach reading it
I'm so glad you enjoyed the book and I
really appreciate your support so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I'm playing a cowboy at the moment so
I'm I've got to do loads of things that
kids do like I got to be a medieval
warrior I got to be a cowboy I've been a
spy I've been a gladiator I've got to
like play around man it was a lot of fun
do you remember the audition for Jon
Snow
I had a black eye I've been in a fight
the night before I'd got in this fight
with this guy in McDonald's I went into
the McDonald's and with this gala was
sort of dating at the time it was late
at night and there was no seats they
asked this some this guy and this girl
he was with if we could sit on the same
table as them and they said yes we sat
down and quite quickly he started being
really rude to the girl I was with cool
you're calling her names and we were
like we'll just finish off it without
any trouble and then then go and then he
called her something like an ugly pig or
something worse and I got up and said
nothing that you can't I can't call her
that get up so I called him up for a
fight which I've never done before and
of course you've been sat down the whole
time so he got up and he just kept going
I just realized that I had to that point
throw the first punch otherwise a little
complete wimp and I got battered so then
I went to the Jon Snow audition with a
black boy which I think that Manny's
punch me in the face may have helped me
get the job so if you're watching thank
you very soon after the the show had
aired and I was dead and suppose a lot
of questions about whether I come back
and that cliffhanger had just started
and the the policeman pulled me over and
for speeding and and I got pulled over
any er sort of he said you know we can
take you into the office and we can give
you a fine and give you points or you
can tell me whether you live in the next
season of Game of Thrones oh my god I
know outrageous and I thought you know
this is a joke this must be a joke and
he was deadly serious and I said well
I'm I'm alive and he said on your way
Lord Commander no fastest Wow
I love that police officer there's
anything better than being alive in
reality is being alive fictionally as
well we did thousands and upon thousands
of tape because it's such a key moment I
think of me going
that they wanted that over and over
again and I had to kind of say I don't
know how else to do it now goes because
I was lying down for so many hours for
two old episodes I mean bro fell asleep
I fell asleep in the middle of a scene
and woke up and and you know when you
wake up you don't look quite where you
are there's nothing scarier than waking
up in the middle of Game of Thrones
world naked and everyone standing over
you thinking oh my god of I've died and
I've actually ended up in Westeros can
you speak a little about the journey
that you've been on with Jon Snow
throughout these seasons Wow it's um
giving incredible journey I spin a
journey all through my 20s all through
his 20s we've sort of grown up together
and it were very hard letting someone
like that go I'll always have an
affinity with with them with him
loved it not playing him I love being
part of the series like it's it's
something that will be one of the most
significant things in my entire life
I'll miss the camaraderie I missed I
missed the going back like like an
office job but to the best office in the
world once every six months I really
will miss that and I missed ever and
I'll miss the crew almost everyone who
works on the show yeah that'll be hard